- Look at this, look at it,
look at it, look closer.
Do you see what is there?
- I would have to say that looks
like someone kissed a toilet.
- But why?
(gentle music)
(water splashing)
All right, so I just found
something crazy on Twitter.
There's this picture that's going viral.
It's like the outline
of lips inside a toilet.
Why would somebody kiss a toilet?
I don't understand, why?
Jade.
- What's up, man?
- Why would somebody kiss a toilet?
(gentle music)
Sarah.
- What?
- Have you seen this?
(laughs) Sorry.
That's funny.
Oh, I know exactly how this happened.
- [Eric] What?
- It's transference.
- (chuckles) Transference?
- Yeah.
- (laughs) What's transference?
(gentle music)
- Like, somebody kissed like a receipt.
- Who kisses receipts?
- Or a napkin.
That's the only way I can
imagine this happening.
What were the other theories?
- There was theories that she vomited,
and went like (gagging).
And like, kind of kissed it.
Should we just annoy
people around the office?
I mean, they don't look
like they're doing anything.
- They're probably on Twitter
anyway, looking at this.
- Yeah, they're probably all talking
about this anyway right now.
- I feel like we need a good science mind.
Do you have any scientific
theories as to how it got there?
- A girl put her face to a toilet bowl.
- But why?
- Some people have freaky fetishes.
- That's what I was saying.
- Okay, but you said--
- And they're not freaky
fetishes, it's a lifestyle.
(all laugh)
- Odd fetishes I seemed to acquired.
"It started at home
when I got a sudden urge
"to kneel down and lick the toilet clean.
"Not just the seat, but
the rim in the bowl."
(gasps) Oh, I'm upset already.
I don't wanna read this.
So, somebody could have wanted to kiss it,
like, in a sexual way.
I just hope that they're using protection.
- I would have to say that
this was probably a dare.
Someone definitely made $10 off of this.
Which is upsetting.
- $10?
- Because they should have
made much more than that.
Because that's where poop
goes, I've seen toilets.
This is where poop-y goes.
Once to poop, twice to goop.
- What does that mean, Dave?
(laughs)
Dave, what does that mean?
- I am familiar with this image.
I think the first time I saw this image
was on a Subreddit called reddit/r/hmm.
Which is like picture that make you think.
I honestly think maybe someone
had just cleaned the toilet,
and thought of the idea,
and thought that this could be
a funny cursed image for the internet.
This is the work of a genius.
- This is a genius, this is purposeful.
They knew, this was planted,
this was a planted kiss.
- I think so.
I want to try to look up where I saw it,
and send that to you,
and see if we can get any
more background on it.
- All right, thank you, please.
- Of course.
- Erin's on the case.
- I'm on it, I'm on it.
- So, I'm out on the streets now.
I got a microphone just
to look professional.
So, right now, we're going to figure out
who kissed the toilet bowl.
Can I ask you a few questions?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, bad start.
Can I ask you a few questions real quick?
(fun music)
Oh, please, I need it.
Can I ask you guys a few
questions real quick?
(fun music)
Aw, all right.
Can I ask you a few questions?
- Sure.
- Yeah?
Have you ever kissed a toilet bowl?
- Never, I try to stay as
far away from it as possible.
- Okay, so this is the picture.
I need to know how it happened.
(fun music)
- Oh, shit, that's in Russia.
- Do you want me to be graphic?
- Go for it, whatever.
- She was getting (beeps), bent over,
and her (beeps) hit the toilet bowl
while she was getting (beeps).
- Someone was having sex, and
just kept kissing the toilet?
- Not kissing, just (beeps).
- I don't know, maybe lady's
in love with the toilet.
- Is that a thing is Russia?
- You can never know.
- I mean, there's the
classic drunken night.
- Drunk at night?
- Yeah.
- Is that like from experience?
- No, that's not my shade of lipstick.
- Alcohol does things to you, man.
- We got a lot of theories.
We're getting some dares,
some drunk, some fetish stuff.
No concrete answers.
- Erin just messaged me.
And she said that she found this message.
"I have done this before!
"I blotted oil-based
lipstick on toilet paper,
"tossed to toilet, left unflushed
"only to come back the next day
"and then find the same phenomenon."
Someone's saying this is possible
if the toilet paper with the kiss
is there for a day.
So, we're gonna have
to test that, as well.
She said she used oil-based lipstick.
I have no fucking clue what that means.
Also, my lips are small.
So, I hope this doesn't ruin it.
Oh, this is not my color.
Wow, wait, is that really my--
Those are my lips?
It looks like my mouth's
like this in that.
Do I kiss like that?
Okay, too close, too close for comfort.
And I'm putting it in.
Hey, Mike, can you not pee
in the toilet for 12 hours?
'Cause I'm doing science.
(gentle music)
All right, so it's the next morning.
And I'm going to see whether the lipstick
kiss is still on my toilet.
Oh, my god.
It's not a pretty kiss
but lipstick is on there.
It didn't look at good as the photo,
so I'm gonna keep working,
and I'm gonna find a perfect combination.
So I can be positive
that my theory is correct.
- Sarah.
- What, you're smiling.
I got the answer.
- Oh, you did?
I did too!
So, I tested like a bunch of lipsticks.
I transferred them onto
this blotting sheet,
and then, I pressed it onto the bowl.
You don't actually have
to kiss the toilet bowl,
in order to get the lipstick
kiss onto the toilet.
What?
(fun music)
- Yeah, I'm not kissing a toilet, okay?
(water splashing)
(flag squeaks)